i'm joined now by dr celia assan an
emergency medicine doctor who worked in
intensive care awards during that time
and who lost her father to covet also
joining us louise bennett whose son fred
died of leukemia in may 2020 just over a
week after his 14th birthday covered
restrictions of course at the time
meant that only 10 people could attend
his funeral um ladies it's lovely to
have you both on the programme and and
doctor i hope you don't mind if i just
go straight to louise louise before we
kind of go into
what we've heard from the prime minister
today and indeed yesterday just tell us
just a little bit more about your son
tell us just a little bit about what he
and the family went through in those
last days
um well fred was being treated in great
ormond street hospital we'd been in an
impatient in birmingham and great ormond
street
for a couple of months by that point so
we'd really seen the lockdown measures
slowly increase
um by the time he died in may 2020 only
my husband and i were allowed in the
hospital and that had been the case
for quite some time so none of his uh
his brother none of his other relatives
or friends could see him
um and after he died we came out
into full lockdown so
we weren't able to see um we weren't
able to see friends we weren't allowed
to you know have people come for us we
weren't allowed to
really have any kind of social
interaction with anyone at all
um and neither could fred's friends i
mean they were they're teenagers and
they wanted to be able to get together
and to comfort and support each other
and they weren't able to do that because
mixing wasn't allowed school wasn't
allowed um you know and i think they
would have loved 10 minutes to just get
together and chat about it
having
had the chance now louise to kind of
reflect on
on the death of your son in the
aftermath of it and indeed on the
apology given by the prime minister
yesterday i i wonder what you made of it
do you accept that the prime minister
who himself was close to death with kova
to himself lost his mother during this
extended period of the pandemic do you
accept that the prime minister is
genuinely remorseful given the
experiences of you and and other people
no i don't um and because he's made an
apology that doesn't mean that we have
to accept it
and it's the same apology he made after
dominic cummings was caught broke
breaking loxam rules by driving to bauna
castle back in that time and all of
these um all of these
law all of the law-breaking that has
happened with these parties since then
have come after he apologized for that
and after he said we understand the
anger and frustration of people who've
made enormous sacrifices he
he trots out this line time and time
again but still believes that those laws
don't apply to him and that he doesn't
have to follow them
uh let's bring in then dr arsene saleh
um thanks for joining us in the on the
program today i i wonder again just tell
us just a little bit about your pandemic
what were you doing for the majority of
your time whilst you were working
so for the majority of the time i was uh
working in intensive care during the
first lockdown
in my hospital
i was staying away from my family
i was in full ppe uh the the ppe that
boris johnson just
we've just heard that um he was working
apparently so hard to get um he called
he called um the opposite side of the
house
issuing constant clamor for the ppe uh
for that they provided we didn't get the
ppe in the adequate supplies that we
needed in the early days and healthcare
workers doctors
nurses and other healthcare workers
actually died from contracting covid
even after they raised their own alarm
on not having a sufficient ppe
so
for me
it was a busy time it wasn't one of
partying it wasn't one of socializing in
hospital staff rooms
as alleged by some of boris johnson's
supporters
it was spent if we were going into the
staff rooms it was often to hydrate so
that we could put the pp back on and go
back in
it was interesting hearing the opening
question from kierstama
on
the the one resignation so far by
allegra straston
linked to the christmas party the the
party that she uh joked about
um
not that she went to but she joked about
and that she uh eventually resigned over
um compared to boris johnson
being looked at for up to six parties
that he's attended allegedly um that
invoked memories for me of the time when
my own father
caught covered and died my father died
assange children retired teacher died on
the 28th of december he caught covered
round about the time i think they were
opening their secret centers
well dave well i'm i'm i'm very sorry
for your loss um louise
clearly the the prime minister of the
day you know has an awful lot on his
plate
you know dealing with the cove dealing
with the coveted pandemic of course that
still carries on the economic fallout
the situation in ukraine is there any
merit in your mind louise to the
argument that you know at a time like
this
when continuity perhaps in our
politicians
would be seen by some as an advantage
particularly if you're dealing with
international diplomacy is there any
weight to that argument that boris
johnson should not be stepping aside
right now because of the enormity of the
task that he and his colleagues face
um no because i think the logical
conclusion of that argument is that
people who have very important jobs
can't be criticized because their jobs
are too important and that's obviously
not a situation that we want to be in i
think given the importance of the job
and given the multiple crises
threatening the country and the world at
the moment
it's even more important than we have a
leader who has integrity and who shows
that leadership and
constantly saying my job is really
important you can't be mean to me
i think he's completely undermining the
the gravitas of his role
i will just uh get a final word from
someone else whose job is incredibly
important um doctor
what what are your thoughts at the
moment on the way in which the covert
pandemic is going i mean how how busy
are you currently as the prime minister
himself is getting on with the job
yeah look i i kind of want to come back
on that last question boris johnson's
method of government by dinner table
it's not fit for the 21st century and
the social problems that we're facing
both domestically and internationally
what we need
definitely on the front line within the
house workforce is a is a prime minister
and a government that we can trust this
government have let us down as a a as a
section of the workforce that has been
on the front line it's let down the
patients it's let down the public as we
go into the public inquiry into the
government's handling of of the pandemic
we need to feel confident that it's
being it will be truly independent at
the moment with the government's hand
even right now in the way that this
independent inquiry
is being drafted i don't have confidence
they are even deciding the terms of
reference
dr
assan and louise bennett thank you both
very much for coming on and indeed for
speaking so kindly really appreciate it